What do millennials want? Independence, work-life balance, recognition. When studying the latest generation to enter adulthood, psychology professor and author, Gene Twenge, came across some surprising findings. In this episode, she talks about how and why millennials are changing the meaning of individualism in today's society. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Gene Twenge is a professor of psychology at San Diego State University and the author of the best-selling books, Generation Me, and The Narcissism Epidemic. As a consultant, she advises companies and organizations on the differences between generations, the boomers, Gen Xers, and Millennials. Welcome, Dr. Twangy. Thank you.
千禧一代想要什么？独立、工作与生活的平衡、认可。在研究最新一代步入成年的人群时，心理学教授兼作家吉恩·特温格（Gene Twenge）发现了一些令人惊讶的结果。在本期节目中，她将探讨千禧一代如何以及为何在当今社会改变了个人主义的含义。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）。吉恩·特温格是圣地亚哥州立大学的心理学教授，也是畅销书《我的一代》（Generation Me）和《自恋流行病》（The Narcissism Epidemic）的作者。作为顾问，她为企业和组织提供有关不同代际之间差异的建议，包括婴儿潮一代、X世代和千禧一代。欢迎您，特温格博士。谢谢。
Millennials, what makes them different from previous generations? What makes them similar? So let's talk about some of the differences first. So millennials tend to have very positive views. of themselves and are very optimistic about their expectations for their lives. And they're more likely to say that they're above average compared to their peers. And they tend to score higher on other measures of positive self-feas, like self-esteem and even narcissism. At the same time, they are more tolerant and less prejudicial than previous generations. So they support same-sex marriage in a much higher rate than other generations, for example.
千禧一代，是什么让他们与前几代人不同？又是什么让他们相似？让我们先谈谈一些差异。千禧一代往往对自己有非常积极的看法，对生活充满乐观的期望。他们更有可能认为自己比同龄人更优秀。在其他衡量积极自我评价的指标上，如自尊甚至自恋，他们往往得分更高。与此同时，他们比前几代人更具包容性，偏见更少。例如，他们支持同性婚姻的比率远高于其他代际。
And some things we're doing right now, they have a much more egalitarian view of gender roles compared to what, say, boomers did when they were young back in the 1960s and 70s. And, of course, not everything is going to change over the generations. Millennials are just as likely as previous generations. For example, to want to get married and have a family. They're similar in a lot of their goals and values. that there's also some fairly distinct differences in the way they see the world. And they tend to, as a very general rule, be more focused on themselves and less focused on things outside themselves compared to the way boomers and Gen Xers were at the same age.
目前我们正在做的一些事情是，与20世纪60年代和70年代年轻时的婴儿潮一代相比，他们对性别角色的看法要平等得多。当然，并非所有事情都会随着代际更替而改变。例如，千禧一代和前几代人一样，都希望结婚并组建家庭。他们在许多目标和价值观上是相似的。但他们看待世界的方式也存在相当明显的差异。总的来说，与同龄时的婴儿潮一代和X世代相比，他们往往更关注自己，而较少关注自身以外的事物。
And as you said, they do tend to view themselves positively. Can you explain a little bit more about this finding? Is it related to upbringing? Is it society in general? You know, where is that coming from? Yeah. So the positive self-fuse, more than likely, are rooted in the cultural movement toward more individualism. So in cross-cultural psychology, people talk about countries like the U.S. being very high in individualism, more focused on the self-and-sexual rules and less on social roles in the society, compared to a culture like Japan, which is less self-focused and has more rigid social rules and more focus on,
正如您所说，他们确实倾向于积极地看待自己。您能多解释一下这个发现吗？这与成长环境有关吗？还是与整个社会有关？您知道，这源于哪里？是的。这种积极的自我评价很可能植根于向个人主义发展的文化运动。在跨文化心理学中，人们谈论美国等国家时，认为其个人主义程度很高，更关注自我和个人规则，而较少关注社会规则，这与日本等文化形成对比，后者较少以自我为中心，拥有更僵化的社会规则，并且更多地关注……
on others, basically. So what I'm trying to look at as the big picture is how has the culture of the U.S. changed over time. And the theme that really comes up over and over is that individualism has increased. And it's not just this generation. It shows up across people of all ages. It shows up in our language use. So one of my favorite recent studies, we looked at the Google Books database over time.
基本上是关注他人。所以我试图从宏观角度观察的是美国文化如何随时间变化。真正反复出现的主题是个人主义的增强。这不仅仅是这一代人的特征，它出现在所有年龄段的人群中。它体现在我们的语言使用中。我最近最喜欢的研究之一是，我们观察了谷歌图书数据库随时间的变化。
and found that the use of I, me, and mine increased while the use of we and us went down. But the biggest change was in you. The use of you actually quadrupled and all the second person pronoun. So you think about that in a book. If you're reading a book and it says you, it's much more individualized.
发现“我”（I）、“我的”（me, mine）的使用频率增加了，而“我们”（we, us）的使用频率下降了。但最大的变化在于“你”（you）。“你”这个第二人称代词的使用频率实际上翻了四倍。所以你在书中思考一下。如果你正在读一本书，里面出现了“你”，它会显得更加个人化。
It's the author having a conversation with the reader. And it echoes some of the self-help language of your best life. So this is a trend that really goes beyond just the millennials. They reflect this trend. so much because this is the only world that they have ever known. So that's why I call them Generation Me, because they have never known a world that put duty before self. And as you mentioned, this also plays into the idea that more recent generations are more
这是作者在与读者进行对话。它呼应了一些关于“活出最好的自己”的自助语言。所以这不仅仅是千禧一代的趋势。他们之所以如此强烈地反映了这一趋势，是因为这是他们所知的唯一世界。这就是为什么我称他们为“我的一代”，因为他们从未经历过将责任置于自我之上的世界。正如您提到的，这也与最近几代人更……
tolerant of others. Is it more because they just realize that every person is an individual and they're able to recognize that? I'm curious what your research has shown. Yeah, that's exactly right. And at this point that connection is, little bit more theoretical than some of these other findings. In general, if you look cross-culturally, individualistic cultures do tend to be more tolerant. But there's not as much work on that as you'd expect. So that's something that's kind of an area for future research. But in terms of the trends over time, it's very clear that there's much more gender equality, racial equality, equality based on sexual orientation, all of these things have increased in our culture in the last 50 years
包容他人有关。是因为他们意识到每个人都是独立的个体，并且能够认识到这一点吗？我很好奇您的研究显示了什么。是的，完全正确。在这一点上，这种联系比其他一些发现更具理论性。总的来说，如果你进行跨文化观察，个人主义文化确实往往更具包容性。但关于这方面的研究并没有你预期的那么多。所以这是未来研究的一个领域。但就随时间变化的趋势而言，很明显，性别平等、种族平等、基于性取向的平等，所有这些在过去50年里在我们的文化中都有所增加。
or so. Just enormous amounts of change, things that used to be taken for granted as social rules are no longer. And many of those changes are really beneficial in that they're treating people as individuals rather than members of groups, that you can see someone as for who they are, rather than saying, well, you're a woman, so you need to do this, or you're gay so you can't get married. Those attitudes are not as accepted anymore. And that's one of those positive things about this cultural shift toward more individualism. I'm curious, and I don't know how far back your research goes as far as generations, but it seems like things are moving faster, and social change is moving faster.
大约50年左右。发生了巨大的变化，曾经被视为理所当然的社会规则已不再适用。其中许多变化确实是有益的，因为它们将人们视为个体而非群体成员，你可以看到一个人的本质，而不是说“好吧，你是女性，所以你需要做这个”或者“你是同性恋，所以你不能结婚”。这些态度不再被广泛接受。这就是这种向个人主义转变的文化中积极的一面。我很好奇，我不知道您的研究在代际方面追溯到了多远，但似乎事情发展得更快了，社会变革正在加速。
Comparatively, I'm talking about hundreds of years. I mean, are we looking at in the last 50 years or so a more dramatic shift? Or is it changing slowly more steadily over time? You know, I think it depends on the particular trade or attitude. You know, it varies. So I think for individualism, there's been a lot of other authors who have made this case, too, about individualism increasing. And at least one says individualism has probably been increasing in Western nations since the Renaissance.
相比之下，我指的是几百年的跨度。我的意思是，我们是在观察过去50年左右发生的更剧烈的转变吗？还是它在随时间缓慢而稳定地变化？我认为这取决于具体的特征或态度。我认为，对于个人主义，也有很多其他作者提出了同样的观点，即个人主义正在增加。至少有一位作者认为，自文艺复兴以来，个人主义可能一直在西方国家增加。
But he argues that that really took off, really accelerated beginning in the 1970s. And that's certainly what the data seems to look at, too, like some of those Google Book Studies. That's when a lot of these changes really took place. But it really does vary. A lot of the generational changes in terms of these positive self-use, they happened in the 1970s and 1980s and then have leveled off. Same thing for some of the increases in anxiety and depression.
但他认为，这种趋势在20世纪70年代开始真正起飞并加速。这当然也是数据所呈现的样子，比如那些谷歌图书研究。那时许多变化确实发生了。但它确实存在差异。许多关于积极自我评价的代际变化发生在20世纪70年代和80年代，然后趋于平稳。焦虑和抑郁的增加也是如此。
But then there's other areas, say like equal rights for gays and lesbians, or equal rights for women where there was a lot of change in the 70s. And then again, there was kind of a plateau in the 80s and 90s, and then just since 2000, there's been more change. So there's some interesting patterns. It's not always completely in one direction. There's times when there's lulls in the progress or lulls in the trend. But we're definitely living in a time now shaped by technology
但也有其他领域，比如男女同性恋的平等权利，或者女性的平等权利，在70年代发生了很大变化。然后在80年代和90年代出现了一种停滞，自2000年以来又发生了更多变化。所以有一些有趣的模式。它并不总是完全朝一个方向发展。有时进步或趋势会出现停滞。但我们现在确实生活在一个由技术塑造的时代。
in these things which may be accelerating cultural change. And I think that's another great area for future. your research too, is to find out which eras have the most change and, you know, have things really accelerated. Why is it important for companies and organizations to understand the characteristics or the personalities of their employees and, you know, the generational differences that come into play in the workplace? It's really crucial to have a view of which differences among those young workers that
这些事物可能会加速文化变革。我认为这也是未来研究的一个很好的领域，即找出哪些时代变化最大，以及事情是否真的加速了。为什么企业和组织了解员工的特征或个性，以及职场中出现的代际差异很重要？了解这些年轻员工中出现的差异是非常关键的……
you're seeing. Which of those are really due to generation and which of those are due to age? because you can look at those young workers and you can think, man, I never did that. I never showed up late for work. But really? Really? Is that really true?
你所看到的。哪些真正归因于代际，哪些归因于年龄？因为你可以看着那些年轻员工，心想：“天哪，我从来没那样做过。我从不迟到。”但真的吗？真的吗？那真的是事实吗？
I'm sure you probably did, and you probably just have this rosy view of the past. So what we really need is to try to find data that compares these young workers now to what young workers used to be like, say, in the 1990s or in the 1970s. That'll show us if they're really our generational or time period differences, or whether it's just due to being young or, due to your memory being faulty or some other thing.
我相信你可能也做过，你可能只是对过去有一种玫瑰色的滤镜。所以我们真正需要的是尝试寻找数据，将现在的年轻员工与20世纪90年代或70年代的年轻员工进行比较。这将向我们展示这是否真的是代际或时间段的差异，还是仅仅因为年轻，或者是因为你的记忆有误或其他原因。
So some business school colleagues and I started looking at this recently, and we were able to find an overtime data set going back to the 70s that asks a bunch of great questions about what people want out of a job, how central they think work is to their lives, all those things that managers really want to know about this young generation and what motivates them. We're able to look at that really in depth and take age out of the equation because everybody was the same age in this sample.
所以我和一些商学院的同事最近开始研究这个问题，我们能够找到一个追溯到70年代的长期数据集，它询问了一系列关于人们对工作的期望、他们认为工作在生活中占据多大比重等重要问题，这些都是管理者真正想了解的关于这一年轻一代及其激励因素的信息。我们能够深入研究这些数据，并将年龄因素排除在外，因为在这个样本中每个人的年龄都是一样的。
They were all about 18 years old, so either entering their careers, they're going to do so in a few years after college. And the biggest difference that we found was in work-life balance or leisure values, that Gen X, and especially the millennials, were much more likely to say they wanted a job with more vacation, that was more flexible,
他们大约都是18岁，要么刚开始职业生涯，要么在大学毕业几年后开始。我们发现最大的差异在于工作与生活的平衡或休闲价值观，X世代，尤其是千禧一代，更有可能表示他们想要一份假期更多、更灵活的工作。
they thought that work was going to be a less central part of their lives. So this all suggests, you know, just as one thing that managers really need to understand, that this generation that they're seeing in the workplace, that, yeah, they'll do good work for you, but they really, really crave that flexibility and they want to be able to have work-life balance and be able to have their lives outside of work as well. And that was a reasonably big difference. That was more than half a standard deviation because there's been some skeptics who have said, oh, you know, yes, there's some differences, but really, you know, they're pretty small. Well, that's a reasonably big difference.
他们认为工作在他们生活中所占的比重会降低。所以这一切都表明，正如管理者真正需要理解的一点，他们所看到的这一代职场新人，是的，他们会为你做好工作，但他们确实非常渴望灵活性，他们希望能够实现工作与生活的平衡，并能够在工作之外拥有自己的生活。这是一个相当大的差异。这超过了半个标准差，因为有一些怀疑论者说：“哦，是的，确实有一些差异，但实际上它们很小。”好吧，这是一个相当大的差异。
have the standard deviation. That's enough for twice as many to say that having a lot of vacation was really important. So that difference at the average multiplies into really, really big differences when you look at the top and the bottom of the distribution. So point being, yeah, it is absolutely true. There's overlap between the generations. It's not that, you know, millennials are way over here on this side and boomers are way over on the other. But there are differences that do really shape recruiting and retaining and managing this generation that weren't around 20 years ago or 40 years ago. Okay, well, great. Thank you, Dr. Twengi. I really appreciate you taking the time to speak with us. You're welcome. It was fun. For more information
半个标准差。这足以让两倍多的人表示拥有大量假期非常重要。因此，当你看分布的顶部和底部时，平均值的差异会放大成非常非常大的差异。所以重点是，是的，这是绝对正确的。代际之间存在重叠。并不是说千禧一代完全在这一边，而婴儿潮一代完全在另一边。但确实存在一些差异，这些差异确实影响了对这一代人的招聘、留任和管理，而这些差异在20年前或40年前是不存在的。好的，太棒了。谢谢你，特温格博士。非常感谢您抽出时间与我们交谈。不客气。这很有趣。欲了解更多信息……
on Twengi's research and to hear more episodes, go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于特温格的研究并收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。